[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi this is Miguel concepción a tattered
gamespot speaking on behalf of Justin
Clark who took a look at Skyrim on
PlayStation VR of its many ports over
the last six years Skyrim on psvr marks
the first time that Elder Scrolls 5
feels fundamentally different from the
original game it's one thing to see the
fantasy realm of Tamriel on a fresh 4k
TV it's another to physically look up
and see the red moon in a starry sky to
instinctively not back to greet passing
NPCs to stare down bloodthirsty dragons
while charging into battle seeing the
same old world from a new perspective
dissolves the lingering feeling that
you've seen it all before
the big appeal of Skyrim has always been
its sense of scale Tamriel is a world
full of life detail and people who don't
just exist for your benefit but have
lives of their own despite the
relatively low res representation of the
world as seen through a PS VR headset
within a few minutes the pixel count
fades in your mind as the illusion of
presence takes hold in VR Tamriel feels
like home a place to embody your
custom-made adventurer
it's a feeling no version can match and
more impressively it grounds you in a
land that can instill wonderment and
dread in equal measure
given Skyrim's expansive world movement
and VR is tricky at first you still have
the option of using the DualShock 4 to
play the game but there's a nauseating
psychological disconnect when using
analog sticks to control movement and
perspective in VR instead the best ways
to play with to PlayStation Move
controllers by default you can hold the
left PS Move button point at a location
and release to instantly teleport to it
alternatively you can switch to direct
movement or you tilt the controller in
any direction and simply hold the left
PS Move button to walk your weapons are
controlled naturally swinging your
controller to swing your weapon and
while there's no reasonable way to
account for the heft of a sword it's
hard not to get into character when the
pressures on magic fares best and dual
wielding spells is a power trip unlike
any other it's the more incidental side
of Skyrim where the motion controls fair
bit worse the gesture based inventory
management is largely unintuitive and
it's all too easy to stumble into a
comedy of errors when attempting simple
tasks at best a mistake might pull you
into a menu by accident at worse you
might drop an item down a mountain while
enveloping yourself in the upgrade menu
starry sky offers one of the more
impressive moments in the game actually
getting to the upgrades you want via
gestures is sometimes easier said than
done and disappointingly despite PS VRS
built-in microphone the game's iconic
shouts can't be voiced controlled both
the issues with the move being ill
optimized for the menus stand out all
the more because each second spent
fooling around with items is another
second away from being entranced by
Tamriel sights and sounds
the second Skyrim VR drops you into that
fateful carriage right into the gallows
surrounded by frightened scoundrels the
change in perspective seems to make
every little moment fresh and personal
like never before when the game goes off
the rails and you're running for your
life to escape the threat of all doin's
dragon fire the instant shift in urgency
from my character is in danger too I am
in danger grants even the classic moment
a newfound level of tension even with
the mild learning curve of the Move
controllers wandering the countryside
isn't just a never-ending hike but an
excuse to fall in love once again with
the world Bethesda's built it's all too
easy to lose track of whatever objective
you had in mind and instead aimlessly
traipse through forests follow random
paths to get perfect views of the night
sky or deliberately tread into deep
bodies of water to simply float face-up
downstream the freezing cold of the
Greybeards mountain feels more
convincing than ever and the momentary
stare down against the wolves that hunt
the paths feels personal there's no
doubt that Tamriel is the same place
it's always been but it's fair to save
never seen it like this before
likewise Skyrim is still Skyrim with the
same host of bugs and structural
shortcomings that highlight just how
dated the game has become yet for psvr
there's no game as ambitious and there's
certainly no other part of Skyrim that
offers what this one does VR isn't
currently the ideal way to tackle a 50
plus hour RPG but this new port proves
that it can be done and shows how
breathtaking the results can be
[Music]